welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is day 12 and we're gonna learn
how billionaires overcome their fears
enjoy
[Music]
you are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something is crazy
and i know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out uh where does that
come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly um but
there are just times when something is
important enough
you believe in it enough that you you do
it in spite of
fear so speaking of important things
like people shouldn't think i i i
i should if people should think well i
feel fear about this and therefore i
shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong
if you didn't feel fear um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway
yeah you know actually something that
can be helpful is fatalism
uh to some degree um if you just if you
just accept the probabilities
um then that diminishes fear
so um starting spacex i thought the odds
of success were less than 10
and i just accepted that actually
probably i would just lose
lose everything um but that maybe would
make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward
so that we still do some good um
yeah same with tesla i thought the odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low what motivations do people
need to harness to
try to make change as opposed to just
reading about
change um
that's not supposed to be an easy
question i don't know oh it's it's this
well like i said i think if
if you study engineering and and you
figure out how to design new things
then it's relatively easy to start a
company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you
and then focus on creating a prototype
compelling prototype as soon as possible
and then that you know there's a there's
a strong venture
capital industry in this in this country
that will give you funding to take
things to the next level
um and that that's all there is to it um
and you might
if you try it a few times you might may
or may not succeed but um
i think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much
um you know they have to say really
what's worse that could go wrong you're
not going to stop to death
you're not going to die of exposure
what's the worst that could go wrong
tell people your your concept of the
paddle well there's a panel for
everybody's ass we all know that
and uh every day you just get up and i
don't fear anything but i worry about
everything
and the day you stop worrying in good
times
the paddle will get you behind and and
and so
as great as things are in life i i know
you're
only a few steps or a few incidents away
from something bad happening you can
never forget it
did you have fear as a kid and you just
got into enough
business scuffles that you figured your
way through things or have you always
been fearless i'm pretty fearless but i
do worry about everything
but you know once again you know the
book and this is why
harper's asked me to write the book
because of all my tillman isms
you got to know what you know and what
you don't know and
and i knew that i understood business
now don't ask me
to you know go win an emmy i took guitar
lessons for four years and i still
struggle playing a guitar
i can't draw a stick person very good
but i knew that i understood business so
i i
know what i know and i know how to do
due diligence on a deal i don't worry
about making a bad deal because i feel
like
that's what i know so no fear when it
comes to that
i'm not afraid to be wrong like i just
think being wrong
is overrated in the north american
philosophy we
we really look there are certain times
where you can't be wrong
if you're a pilot you can't be wrong or
a surgeon i get that
or if you're no it's not true actually
surgeons make mistakes all the time
they leave you know utensils or whatever
not utensils
the things inside the people's bodies i
mean you know
but i i get how certain professions need
to value
the sort of like the binary distinction
of right and wrong
but i think for most of us um it's
really sort of like you're either
learning or you're not learning
and i think we right now we create too
much of like a god complex around being
right
and we don't celebrate enough like the
fun process of iterating
you know and being able to like be in
the grind with people and
like like laugh when things don't work
that it's not like the end of the world
um
so i i think to me like that's probably
the single biggest thing that people
have to
uh get comfortable with which is like
just you're learning you're learning
and you either care about that or you
don't like if you're a good entrepreneur
like we were talking about this in the
green room nobody should grow up to be
an entrepreneur
i'm sorry that's i agree that's
ridiculous
you should grow up to be really angry
about something in your life
that you want to fix or change to make
better
do you know what i'm saying yes
um because then all of a sudden like
you're not going to give up when
something doesn't work
when something is wrong you're just
going to keep working at it because it's
learning but that mindset is only
possible in that context
so i i don't know i just think like
that's a that's a really important thing
to really internalize
i think failure and your attitude and
the way that you embrace
the fear of failure is a big part of
where we end up in our lives
and my father used to at the dining room
table
asked my brother and me what we failed
at
and he used to encourage us to fail so i
can remember being at the dining room
table
and he would say sarah would you fail it
this week
and if i didn't have something to tell
him he'd be disappointed
i can remember coming home and sitting
at the dining room table and saying dad
dad i tried out for this and i was
horrible and he would say way to go and
high five me
and those teachings and that principle
that was such a gift for me as a child
actually came from wayne dyer
my dad had been listening to a series
called what do you really want for your
children
and so i got the benefit and so did my
brother of this sort of
different way of parenting and thinking
and for me
it redefined failure failure was no
longer
for me the outcome failure was not
trying
i think just you said what people don't
know about me so i was trying to think
about it but i'm most proud of the fact
that
um that i was able to to achieve this in
a really
um kind way you know that i can
look at myself in the mirror and just i
am where i am and i feel really good
about it
really good about myself i didn't feel
like i had to compromise
you know when i first started spanx i
was at a cocktail party and three guys
came up to me and they said sarah we
heard you just started your
a business and invented something and i
said yes and they go
you know business is war and i just
looked at him and
and then one guy you know pat me on the
back and he said yeah i hope you're up
for it
i hope you're ready for war wow and i
went home that night in my apartment and
i sat down on the floor and i literally
started crying and i remember thinking i
don't want to go to war
like why does it have to be war i want
to go about this in a completely
different way
and so the whole journey of spanx i
really took a feminine
approach to it i mean i i def i didn't
know business i'd never taken a business
class i didn't have a business plan
i didn't go out and raise vc so i
trusted my gut i
stuck with intuition i you know
just did things what felt
very yeah i think traditional business
has been very
male energy and so i wanted to see what
would happen if i took a very
feminine energy approach there are
things that i
think are quite impossible improbable
and i hope they don't happen but that
doesn't mean they won't happen
i mean for example in our insurance
business we could have
the world's or the country's
number one hurricane that it's ever had
but that doesn't preclude the fact we
could have
the biggest earthquake a month later so
we we
we are not we don't prepare ourselves
for a single problem
we prepare ourselves for problems that
that
sometimes create their own momentum i
mean 2008 and
9 you didn't see all the problems the
first day
when uh really what really kicked it off
was when the
the freddie and fanny the gses
went into conservatorship in early
september and
and then when uh
money market funds broke the buck i mean
there are there are things to trip other
things and
and we take a very much a worst case
uh scenario into mine that
probably is a considerably worse case
than
than most people do so i don't look at
it as
as huge and i'm not i'm not recommending
that people buy stocks
today or tomorrow or next week or next
month i think it all depends on your
circumstances but you shouldn't buy
stocks unless you expect in my view
you you expect to hold them for a very
extended period and you are prepared
financially and psychologically
to hold them the same way you would hold
a farm and never look at a quote and
never
uh never pay it you don't need to pay
attention to them i mean
the main thing to do and you're not
going to pick the bottom and you're not
going to
nobody else can pick it for you or
anything of the sort you've got to be
prepared
when you buy a stock then have it go
down 50
or more and be comfortable with it as
long as you're comfortable with the
holding and i pointed out
i think a year maybe two years ago on
the annual report
uh well just the one before this most
recent one
i pointed out that there have been three
times in berkshire's history
when the price of berkshire stock went
down 50 percent three different times
now if you owed it on borrowed money
you would you know you could have been
cleaned out uh there wasn't anything
wrong with berkshire
uh when those three times occurred but
if you're going to if you're going to
look at the
price of the stock uh and think that you
have to act because it's doing this or
that or somebody else tells you why
you know how can you stay with that when
something else is going up or anything
you really you've got to be in the right
psychological position and frankly
some people are not really careful some
people are more
subject to fear than than others it's it
it
it's it's like the virus it strikes uh
some people with uh much greater
ferocity than
than others and and fear is uh
there is something i really never felt
financially but but
i don't think charlie's followed either
but uh
some people can handle psychology if you
can't handle it psychologically
then you really shouldn't know sucks
because you're going to buy and solve
the wrong time and
you should not count on somebody else
telling you
you should do something you understand
yourself if you don't understand it
yourself you're going to be affected by
the next person you talk to
and so you should you should
be in a position to hold and i don't
know whether today is a
a great day to buy stocks i know it will
work out over 20 or 30 years
i don't know whether it'll work out over
two years at all i have no idea whether
you'll be
ahead or behind on a stock you buy on
monday morning
the whole point of of moving things
forward is you
run into problems you run into failures
things don't work you have to back up
and try again
each one of those times when you have a
setback and you back up and you try
again
you're using resourcefulness you're
using self-reliance you're trying to
invent your way out of a box and um i
have we have
tons of examples at amazon where we've
had to do this we've failed so many
times we have
the ios think of us as a great place to
feel because we're good at it we have so
much practice
and i get just to give you one example
we
many years ago now we started we wanted
a third party uh selling business
because we knew we could add selection
to the store that way
and uh we started amazon auctions
nobody came i think maybe our mother the
only one who purchased something i
bought a coffee cup
you got a coffee cup okay so there were
two purchasers
and um and and that's so then we said
what can we do we opened this thing
called
z shops we train which was like fixed
price auctions again nobody came
i didn't use that and then finally and
each one of these failures is like a
year year and a half long
and so we're trying to invent new things
and we finally came across this idea of
of putting the third party selection on
the same
detail page as the same product detail
pages that we had our own inventory on
our own retail inventory on
we we called this marketplace and it
started working right away and
so that just that resourcefulness of
trying new things
figuring things out what the customers
really want it
pays off in everything and it pays off
even in your daily lives
to be innovative you have to experiment
if you want to have more invention
you need to do more experiments per week
per month per year per decade it's that
simple
you cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail if you know it's going
to work in advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that amazon's a big organization now too
the air force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation
with operational excellence so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles at amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just
a failure that's not the kind of failure
we're seeking
we want failures where we're trying to
do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale sizes
from the very beginning um in 1994 when
i came across this fact that the web was
growing at 2300 a year
i was working on wall street very
specialized kind of investment bank
called a quantitative hedge fund and a
company called de shaw
and i uh when i
decided i was going to go do this crazy
thing i went and told my boss
and he said well hmm let's go for a walk
so we went on a two-hour walk in central
park
and he actually thought it was a good
idea he's a very smart guy his name is
david shaw he's one of the few people i
know who has a fully developed left
brain affordable right brain just a
super smart guy
and he said this is a great uh idea but
it would be a better idea for somebody
who didn't already have a good job
and um
and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me
and so i went away he convinced me to
think about it for two more days
and it was very hard to make that
decision
and until i found the right framework in
which to make the decision i think
because i know there are a lot of people
who are interested in
entrepreneurial activities out there i
think this could be useful
it's it's that it's the right framework
for me anyway to make the kind of
decision was a regret minimization
framework
so i projected myself into the future
and i'm 80 years old and i'm looking
back on my life
what do i want to have done at that
point i want to minimize all the regrets
that i have
and i knew that when i was 80 there was
no chance that i would
regret having walked away from my 1994
wall street bonus or any of that kind of
thing i wouldn't even remember that
but i did think there was a chance that
i might regret not having participated
somehow and this thing that i thought
was going to be very exciting
called the internet and and i also knew
that if i tried and failed i wouldn't
regret that so once i thought about it
that way
it become became incredibly easy to make
that decision
when you do business my rule is never be
a fear
never worry about a competition never
worry about um
you know the the pressures
if you worry about the pressure you will
worry about a competition if you're
worried about this
don't do don't be a businessman and
today the good thing is the whole world
worries everywhere people worry about
data people worry about
privacy people worry about security
people worry about
anything that normally
is that means great opportunity comes
because you know you cannot stop this
the internet time is coming
mobile time is coming back data is
coming you cannot stop
not worry with the only thing is you
embrace you change yourself
and start to do it and is there any
system
no if you have a system you never worry
nobody has a system asking a president
he doesn't have a system
right if you're a human being your
worries your doubts
but the only difference when you doubt
you will you fix the problem
you change yourself you fight again
tomorrow when i went back to china in
1995 with an
idea of the internet was very strange
china was not connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is
internet nobody say ah this thing never
work this thing never exists
um because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china red company
registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo
hope internet company
the guy looked at me saying this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's
no word called the internet why you want
a registered company called the internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but i
in 1995 in
later august china was connected the
internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we they just try to take the picture
i i
die from houngsu to shanghai shanghai to
america to connect the internet
it took us three hours and a half to
download the first
front of the page at that time there is
no net escape called the mosaic
oh so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my
journalists friends to stay and wait
because to prove that i'm not telling a
lie
foreign
[Music]
some of the best advice i've heard you
give is
don't be afraid to close your eyes and
dream
and to open them up and see
and that's a beautiful quote because
it's all about
what can be but also what is
so what can the audience tonight take
away from
why that is one of your favorite quotes
um it's one of my favorite quote quotes
i came up with it
with my uncle i had an uncle named uncle
shrimp and
uncle shrimp he was a short kind of guy
you know lost his hair
like the age 20 so he's bald-headed and
he was just so charismatic um
and he told me this after i injured
myself and i realized that i wasn't
going to be a football player
and and he told me you know to never
lose sight of your dreams but he also
told me this
as who i was he knew
that now was going to be a turning point
either i could have turned to the
streets
and followed in the footsteps of my
father or i could dream the impossible
dream
right and um he also wanted me to notice
as an african-american man
because you know that fear of
having a dream and that fear of oh i
can't dream that that
you know i can't i'll never be able to
do that right you know
um it was important to know that yes you
can have that dream but you have to know
honestly what it's going to take for you
to achieve that dream
and um so then i came up with the quote
and it goes for everybody all genders
all races
you know don't be afraid to close your
eyes and dream but then you have to open
your eyes and see the reality
of what it's going to take for you to
achieve that dream
and a lot of people they kind of see
whether it's musicians or athletes or
entertainers
or even just successful people but they
don't understand
the the thing that it takes for them to
get to the point that they've gotten
and um you know that's why it's a very
important quote to me and i think it
you know it has inspired people and it
inspires me every day
that's true nothing worth having is easy
yes you know and and how hard you have
to work for it yes
one of the things that i wanted to make
sure that i also answered you asked me a
question earlier about fearlessness yeah
i remember you asked me this before
um when we were doing something cans and
you know i told you you have to be
fearless you know you can't be afraid of
anything
right and then i you know um doing this
um cable network it's probably
i mean it's not probably it's the
hardest thing that i've i've ever done
second to um running a marathon because
i almost died running a marathon
so chicago marathon was on sunday
and i'll tell you that story another
time when you'll have me back too
but um you know so i'm in my office
you know like a couple of months ago and
you know
fear overcame me yeah and and i
remembered
that you know i'm fearless in a sense
but
having some sort of fear is a part of
fearlessness yes so i think sometimes we
don't tell that full story
people may not get it it's all right to
have some fears and some insecurities as
you're going through it
but you have to push through that wall
it's almost like if there isn't a little
bit of fear
yeah then you can't be fearless my hope
was never to build a company
i wanted to have an impact and as all
these people started joining us
i just assumed that that's what they
wanted to do too so i never took the
time
to explain what it was that i hoped we'd
build
a couple years in some big companies
wanted to buy us
i didn't want to sell i wanted to see if
we could connect more people
and we were building the first version
of news feed at the time and i thought
if we could just launch this it could
change how we all learn about the world
nearly everyone else wanted to sell
without a sense of higher purpose this
was their startup dream come true
and it tore our company apart after one
particularly tense argument
one of my close advisors told me if i
hadn't agreed to sell the company right
now
i would regret that decision for the
rest of my life
relationships were so afraid that within
a year or so
every single person on our management
team was gone
that was my hardest time leading
facebook
i believed in what we were doing but i
felt alone
and worse it was my fault
i wondered if i was just wrong an
imposter
a 22 year old kid who had no idea how
things
actually worked now
years later i understand that that is
how things work when there's no sense of
higher purpose
so it's up to all of us to create it so
we can all keep moving forward
together fear is the great indicator
sooner or later you will experience
fear when you start taking new actions
at new levels in fact if you
aren't then you're probably not doing
enough of the right things
fear isn't bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek
and then to embrace fear is actually a
sign that you're doing what is needed
to move in the right direction what is
fear anyway i mean really does
it even exist is it real i know it feels
real when you're experiencing it but
admit it
most of the time what you fear doesn't
even occur
fear for the most part is provoked by
emotions
not rational thinking chances are that
when you were a child you've found
fear in irrational things the boogeyman
under the bed for example
adults have their own boogeyman the
unknown rejection
failure fear of success and on and on
for example if you're afraid to call a
client then it's
that sign that you should call that
client fear of speaking with the boss is
an indication you should march into his
office and ask for a moment of his time
everyone everyone experiences fear on
some level
fear doesn't just tell you what to do it
also tells you when to do it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same
the time is now the time is always now
and when you experience
fear it's a sign that the best time to
take action is at that
very moment now the only thing that will
make a difference in that moment of fear
is action failure comes in many forms it
occurs
whether you act or you don't act
regardless of the outcome i would say
it's far preferable to fail while doing
something than to fail by
over preparing while someone else walks
up and scoops up your dreams
fear is a sign to do whatever it is you
fear and do it quickly
remember fear is one of the most
disabling emotions a human being can
experience
it immobilizes people and often it
ultimately
prevents them from going for their goals
and their dreams
look if you're not experiencing fear
you're not taking new action and you're
not growing
fear like fire is something from which
you should never pull away
rather it should be something you use to
fuel the actions
of your life and one thing that
that has helped me whether it was
writing a book and finishing it
or starting my speaking career when i
did it 30 years old
i was going door to door
to businesses around america flew 3
million miles
to go to a city i was living in houston
at the time
in bel air texas and i'd fly to salt
lake city
and i'd call on business owners
i'd set a an event two weeks in advance
commit to the hotel fly to salt lake
city knew no one no one knew me i had no
name no books
there was no social media and
i never felt like doing i was scared to
death
had no clue what i was doing didn't know
who i was calling on
don't even know how much i believed in
what i was doing like i did believe in
it
but it was like you know i didn't have
any statistics or
facts or success stories
and regardless of how i felt
just like this morning regardless how
much doubt there was or uncertainty
fear
no matter who you're watching or who
you're following
whether it's a political
person a rapper
movie star teacher coach
parents i don't care how much in
confidence they put out how much
athlete how much confidence or
certainty that they push out push out
like like project
they wake up there's days they wake up
and they don't feel it
they don't feel it they don't they don't
want to do it
they're uncertain uh they're feeling
some low grade depression whatever you
want to call it look i woke up like that
this morning i went
got up family's not here this weekend
uh elena's got the kids she's teaching
them how to shoot guns this weekend
and i'm here by myself so i'm waking up
this morning like i don't want to work
out i missed yesterday
i'm not feeling it so what do you do
what do you guys do when you don't feel
it
so this is what i do i just get a little
closer
this is what i do i get a little closer
just like i did when i was 30 years old
starting my speaking career never
thought i'd be one of the top
considered one of the top two or three
speakers in the world when i was 30
years old i wanted that
but i didn't know how i was going to get
to that and what i did what
when i was having to fly to these cities
salt lake city winnipeg
saskatoon toronto uh vancouver
chicago new york like i've never even
been to these places i was literally
flying to cities for the first time in
my entire career didn't know the
language didn't know the the culture
didn't know how they
they those little changes and that
happened between toronto and new york
new york and chicago
chicago and dallas and dallas and salt
lake salt lake and la those are all very
very different markets and different
people and different thinking
dude i was terrified okay i'm doing this
today to tell you i was terrified
i was so scared most of the time that it
felt like not fear it felt like
depression like i wanted to take the
flat
the the sheets just pull them over my
head so what i did
to conquer that to handle that i
literally would just get a little closer
i'd get myself a little closer to the
action like this morning i just got
close to the gym i actually wouldn't
walk by the pool
i have a pool in the same spot that we
have a gym on the second floor here
and i walked out there and as i passed
the gym
because they're still doing the social
distancing [ __ ] here
um
there was nobody in here i'm like okay
there's nobody in here it's a sign i'm
gonna go in there and work out okay so
number one just try getting a little
closer to the action hope that helps you
just get a little closer you don't have
to commit to doing it completely
just get closer to it i came down here
dressed
i put that i put that on before i left
so i was ready
so i got a little closer second thing do
if it calls you
do it anyway you know i coined this
phrase years ago
do it anyway a buddy of mine about the
same time i was starting my business
i was having a lot of problems in my
life i was probably
it was before i started my business i
was still in houston texas i was going
through
tremendous tremendous amounts of
uncertainty doubt about myself i was in
a transition a career transition
just lost a job starting my deal
and i went one year
one year without working i've never ever
shared this before
one year and i did not i mean i had a
little bit of money saved and i was
going through it
i didn't i didn't literally i looked
like i was working every day but
in truth i was not working my twin
brother actually knew that and finally
confronted me and that's what got me off
my ass but
this guy told me he's like look you wake
up in the morning and no matter what
you're feeling
no matter how much you hurt if your eyes
are bleeding
do it anyway and that has stuck with me
now for 30
27 28 years do it anyway no matter how
it feels do anyway so number one get a
little closer number two do it anyway
and then number three okay regardless of
the outcome of what you did
when you showed up to present make that
phone call
uh go to the workout once you get in
there
come on man put all you put up put give
it give it the best shot you got
once you're in there once you're in
there once you get going just start
moving
in that direction like i just went and
jumped on that thing for three minutes
the next thing you know i'm like hey
i'm glad i'm in here so third thing once
you get in there
go all the way i know when i was 25
years old
scared to speak in public scared to
approach more than one customer at a
time because i was in sales
i hated sales i i was terrified of the
greeting i was
terrified of breaking um
breaking uh what do you call it uh
building rapport and breaking ice you
know those first
words i was uncomfortable i was insecure
i lacked self-esteem i wanted so badly
to have confidence
i wanted so badly to be you know like
do the do the do the scary things you
know i remember
i remember like man one day i want to be
the i want to be the hero
you know i've never been look i've never
looked for a guru i've never
wanted a guru i've never wanted to be
anybody's guru
guru but i have always wanted to be my
own hero
you know i've always wanted to be
somebody i could go to sleep at night
and say dude i like
me so when i'm 25 years old i didn't
have any of that it literally brings
tears to my eyes when i think back
between the ages of 10
and 25 how how
little i felt how small i felt how
naturally introverted um
i thought i was i wasn't actually an
introvert but i thought i was
introverted and shy and and
small and little and but then i had all
these i had all these ideas in my head
that uh one day i was gonna be something
man it'll drive you freaking crazy when
you feel like this right
in my head i'm like i'm gonna be a
freaking g i'm gonna be a giant one day
and inside i'm feeling all this
insecurity so
um i just want to talk to you a little
bit about fear tonight and how i
overcame it
and it's not very complicated it
definitely does not require hypnotism
in fact i would tell you just the
opposite it's not about
some trick it's not some like definitely
not medication
okay the more medication i took the more
scared i was
uh you know medication's good for a
second and then when you're off the
medication you're like dang dude
i'm scared again you know so so the
thing that helped me
whether it was a speaking career sales
making phone calls i still i still don't
like making phone calls
uh i was scared of being broke
i was scared of getting rich i was
scared of being successful scared of
failure
scared of women uh scared of the right
woman scared of marriage i was scared of
children orlando will tell you some of
this
couldn't commit to relationships
couldn't commit to a job okay i was
scared of of
of giving helping other people too much
and like people are going to take
advantage of me i remember getting in
real estate
and i was scared to tell the buyer of
the seller
that i actually wanted his property you
know i was scared to tell the
the bank the truth so you know i know
people say oh it's false events
appearing real
and you know f everything and run and
all that you know and all these cute
little sayings but all the cute little
sayings
and the instagram posts don't they don't
seem to make the freaking fear go away
i'm 58 years old man i mean i got a lot
of i got a lot of great stuff going for
me
i got a tremendous amount of success in
my life i still just want you to know
i still experience fear so one of the
things i do today
and have done is i have used the i use
fear uh yeah like the irs somebody said
the irs is scary
you know dude look if you don't get if
you don't get you got to change the way
you think about fear and that's really
what i did
because if you don't ever get audited it
means you never made any money
i mean that's the bottom line you got to
think about different things to wish for
you know p people don't want to people
don't want i don't know i don't want to
pay taxes
then you don't make any money all right
or you don't pay taxes then you got a
problem with the ir and the yes
most people can't pay taxes because they
can't they can't
they don't know how to run cash flow so
the reason the way i handle my fear
okay is dude i just said hey what am i
scared of
what am i scared of i made a list of all
the stuff i was scared of
i just made the whole list everything
that i could be scared of rather than
being scared of one thing
i made a list of everything i was scared
of
and i'm like all right what could happen
here
you know what could happen here
see when i take my emotions out of
wherever they're generated i don't know
if they're generated
you know harmonically uh i got i don't
know a trillion cells in my body i don't
know if the cells are actually having
some kind of experience who knows we
don't know what's going on
you know unfortunately medicine you know
and the guys that want to
medicate everybody they they completely
invalidate the possibility that there's
a spiritual being
that's been around a long time that's
having you know i mean it would seem
like a spiritual man could possibly have
memories you know so i mean i don't know
i don't need to go all that i just know
this i need to get it out of my head and
out of an emotional state
and put it down on a piece of paper for
me it's very analytical
you know it's just analytical it's lay
it down on paper man
okay your marriage is suffering lay it
down on paper what can you do to make it
better
you're not spending enough time with the
kids good what could you do to
spend more time with the kids i know
people that are scared of spending time
with their kids because they're going to
spoil them
and scared not to spend time with their
kids because they're going to
they're going to regret it it's a no-win
deal with fear
fear's a no-win deal either way you lose
so i'm like look i'm gonna put this
thing down on paper number one i write
it down and number two i look at it
dude what could happen to me here what's
the worst thing that can happen to me if
i do it
what's the worst thing that happens to
me if i don't do it by the time i made
my list for instance i was 30 years old
and i was starting my business career
i was starting my career speaking i had
to go speak to audiences
to sell my product my product just
didn't sell itself so i had to
make a phone call then i had to go cold
call the guy
or gal the company
and then i had to go speak to them okay
most of the time they hung up on me then
they wouldn't see me and i still had to
get in and once i finally got in to the
guy that hung up on me to the guy or gal
that said what are you doing here and
then finally convinced
me or or accepted me convincing them
to come on in and do a presentation now
i had to talk to their staff
i wrote a list man what am i scared of
what can they do to me ah nothing
yeah but really what can they do to me
okay when you really start getting down
to it i'm gonna look bad
you know fear really i think is
generated because the individual is
selfish
you know you don't want to get hurt
notice who the fearful person's thinking
about that's what i discovered
the scared grant was always trying to
protect grant
and i'm like dude what am i going to be
fearful or selfish
okay if i don't do this stuff i can't
build my career and by the way
if i don't do it why am i not doing it
because i'm selfish
you know i basically just kind of
changed the way i looked at it
analytically i changed
the equation you know it's kind of like
money man you want money sitting at the
bank earning a half a percent
or you want money in in a real estate
deal with me earning 10 percent
it's 20 times the money okay i had a guy
that invested in our deal my sister
actually uh last month says oh the deal
only paid six percent you know i'm like
that was the first month right
okay annualize that over 12 months her
first payment
on the deal was annualized if i take out
take out what she was paid one month it
would be
six percent it still says
12 times 12x the bank
and she's like well only get paid a
quarter of a percent 24 times
the bank see the way to handle fear
is to really really get analytical
okay so if you don't like being scared
find something you don't like even more
than being scared like
selfish because scared people are
selfish people
you know poor people are selfish people
you know why poor people are selfish
people
because they think about themselves too
much i don't have a good job
they don't pay me anymore listen to what
the guy's saying man i've been here i'm
talking about myself now
i'm working at mcdonald's i hate this
place it smells like hamburger i smell
like french fries they don't pay me
enough
the manager's a wanker they don't treat
me right
i hate this uniform what am i talking
about huh
i'm broke man i'm making minimum wage it
was a dollar 75 on minimum wage
when i was uh at minimum wage 1.75
they don't pay me enough poor me poor me
i'm selfish
okay i don't want to go speak to people
i don't want to do cold calls
i don't want to knock on doors i don't
want to get through the gatekeeper dude
you're freaking selfish
and that is how i started handling fear
if you guys look around man it would
appear to me
that 99 of the people that you run into
today
are having some kind of financial
problem
oh 76 percent of americans live paycheck
to paycheck i know people that don't
live paycheck to paycheck that worry
about money every second of every day
when my dad died i didn't know anything
about the one percent but i knew i
wanted to get that club
i'm like i have to get above whatever
this middle-class thing is because
there's no safety here it's constant
fear i've only wanted money for one
reason to be out of fear so i could help
out so i could give to charities so i
could help my brother so i didn't have
to worry about
how much the fuel cost or do i run an ad
budget or not man you guys got to get
out of the fear man that's the whole
purpose okay
the fear by the way is not a conspiracy
that is
real everybody like oh fear ain't real
yeah well uh-huh it's easy for you to
say you ain't got any of this second
okay because it ain't scary to write a
damn quote
or to post something on instagram that
ain't scary what's scary is
going to take a loan for 60 million
dollars
see if you ain't got a little bit of
scare okay
say you know to a customer hey man
you're wrong okay my daughter told me
the other day customers are always right
papa no they're not
no they're not and most people don't
even know how to tell a customer they're
wrong
okay best customers i have i told no
that's not true that's not right
you're wrong and i'll show you why now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
the famous quote of feel the fear and do
it anyway i would
change the feel the fear and do it
because of
because if you want to do great things
you have to teach yourself that you do
scary things that you step out of your
comfort zone
that you embrace difficult challenges
that you do
scary things feel the fear and do it
because of
make that your mantra and your entire
life will change
so recently my friend mark drager friend
of the channel long time friend of the
channel
he helped actually film my very first
video on walt disney that was him behind
the camera
he had an idea that he wanted to shave
his head but
he was anxious he was worried he was
fearful of how it might look of how
people might judge him
of you can't go back from it you know
once you once you shave it it's going to
take a while to grow back
and so he decided that he would just do
it
[Music]
[Applause]
why
[Music]
it looks pretty crazy right now i hope
it looks better when it's done
maybe maybe not we'll see and what i
love about this
is that he decided to do the scary thing
that whether he sticks with having his
head shaved or not doesn't matter it's
it's teaching yourself that you do scary
things that when an idea comes into your
head and the instant voice that comes
back is well that's
scary i don't know if i can do that
every second
that you spend thinking about that and
second
minutes weeks months years decades for
some people
just sitting on the idea and telling
yourself that it's too scary and you
can't do it
you're teaching yourself that you suck
that's what i believe
i really believe that if you want to do
something you've got an idea in your
head
maybe it's shaving your head maybe it's
something else maybe it's asking
somebody out maybe it's starting that
business maybe it's making that phone
call maybe it's writing that book or
making that video
or starting your instagram account
whatever it is we all have these things
that we fear
deciding that you're going to do it
and that it's not because you're
fearless because you are afraid fear is
a great thing if you're fearless then
you're just inside your comfort zone all
the time
think about if you had no fears it means
you're just sitting inside your comfort
zone
and you're not doing anything that is
remotely scary it's feeling the fear and
saying i do
scary things i'm the kind of person
teaching yourself
that you're the kind of person who
follows through on difficult things
on scary things that's how you build
your self-confidence that's how you
build your self-love
mark shaving his head you might think
well what does that have to do with his
business goals
and and progress as an entrepreneur
everything
everything is he going to land more
deals now that he has a shaved head
probably not
but the the self love the
self-motivation
the self-confidence that comes from
teaching yourself if you had that idea
in his head
for weeks or months he's saying i should
do this i should do this and then he's
not doing it he doesn't follow through
the record in his head is i suck i suck
i suck i suck do you think he's gonna be
bold in business
do you think when he comes up with a new
idea for what he should be doing on
on his campaign on his hiring on his
next step that he's gonna take action
heck no
because that loop is in his head saying
you suck you come up with ideas and then
find ways why you can't do it you come
up with
bold initiatives and then don't do them
and play small and they just stay as an
idea
you need to flip it you flip it in every
circumstance as long as it's not against
your ethics or is just plain stupid
right like
don't just jump into a lion's cage
because
you're scared to do it right most of the
things that you're afraid to do
are not actually against your ethics and
are not actually gonna cause physical
harm to you or somebody else
right most of the things you're afraid
to do are revolving other people's
opinions other people's judgments
failing in front of somebody else
and that now is no longer good enough
reason you have to shift the mindset
that when something comes it's difficult
that's scary that's hard that you do it
you're the kind of person
who comes up with genius amazing ideas
and they have to be birthed into the
world you do scary things
just because okay my three-step process
to doing
scary things to getting out of your own
way and making momentum happen in your
business and your life
let's go step number one is use the word
scary difficult of heart
when you hear yourself say scary
difficult or hard
when you're thinking it when you
articulate it that means you have to do
it the fact that i said it's scary means
i have to do it
just because because evan carmichael
does scary things
it's building that identity for yourself
the fact that you were thinking that
this is scary
that is difficult that it's hard those
are not acceptable reasons anymore
for you not to take action you love
scary you love difficult you embrace
hard
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of scary difficult
the heart
so use those words as triggers try to
catch it in yourself again
when you actually say it out loud or
when you're thinking it
or you can use the people around you
your husband your wife your kids your
friends your family
if i ever say scary difficult or hard i
want you to catch me i want you to grab
me i want you to say stop
you just said it you said scary you said
difficult you said hard
now you have to do it just because teach
yourself
step number two is the boom boom boom
test so scary difficult hard is catching
either a thought or catching
the words the boom boom boom test is
paying attention to your body that's
when your heart's going boom
boom boom boom right when you're nervous
when you're feeling like something is
scary difficult or hard
the physical reaction is often your
heart picking up
right your heart's picking up the pace
it's going boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom
so the boom boom boom test is when you
feel it in your body
you have to go that's the trigger as
well that's go time the fact that your
heart is beating
about making a video about posting
instagram about making that phone call
about
you know putting that book title out
there the fact that you're afraid
and your heart speeding is another
signal that you have to go and do it
teach yourself train yourself
when your heart's beating like this
again the caveat you're not hurting
somebody
you're not doing something stupid that's
going to risk your life or somebody
else's
you're not going against your ethics or
your code of values right great
boom boom boom boom you're afraid you do
it you teach yourself boom boom boom you
do it boom boom boom you do it you do it
you do it
teach yourself let's go and set number
three is schedule in triggers
it's easy to kind of get lost in the
day-to-day of life you wake up and you
might have had the best day yesterday
but today you wake up and you start from
scratch and so
scheduling in triggers whether that's
your physical environment here right i
walk in here and these mean something to
me
whether it's videos my own videos the
whole point of making the espresso
series
and the 254 series is starting your day
with with a shot with believe right
bring that for yourself
if surrounding yourself with more mel
robbins is the thing that gets you
feeling
motivated confident ready to go do that
every day if it's me
do that every day if it's elon musk do
that every day
i look at elon and every time i think
i'm thinking big and doing something big
and being bold
i look at elon musk and he's trying to
have a back-up plan for the planet
and i think man i'm thinking so small
and it's amazing right i love it
it's aspirational pulls you forward it's
a play bigger trigger
so what are the triggers that you can
have from from what you wear
to what's in your office your morning
routine the things you consume
that force you to step up and play a
bigger game
the fear of getting negative feedback is
the single biggest reason why people
don't share
create and post more you're afraid of
what people who aren't chasing their
dreams down think of you
and it's preventing you from chasing
your own dreams down
that needs to end you're ready for more
it's time and this video will show you
how
so last night on my twitch stream i had
a woman join me in the comments who was
saying
i'm afraid of saying the wrong thing i'm
afraid of moving forward and taking
action like i need to because i'm afraid
of saying the wrong thing i'm afraid i'm
going to get judged i'm afraid
people are going to laugh at me i'm just
going to say the wrong thing
and this is a bucket a lot of people
fall into every time i make a video i'm
afraid of saying the wrong thing every
time i get on stage i'm afraid i'm going
to say the wrong thing especially when
it's a live format i'm doing an
interview
or i'm on stage or i'm helping somebody
i'm always afraid i'm going to say the
wrong thing because my number one fear
is disappointing people
and so this is a trap we fall into is
we know we're capable of more we know
we're capable of helping i know i'm
capable of helping
but because you're afraid of saying the
wrong thing because you're afraid of
of letting somebody down because you're
afraid of giving the wrong advice what
ends up happening is
you don't do anything you have your foot
in the gas and break at the same time so
your tires are spinning but you're not
moving anywhere
and and you have to learn to let go of
the break
because otherwise you're stuck in this
loop of knowing that you're capable of
more of knowing you have a gift
that can help people and truly make an
impact but you never
start because you're afraid of negative
feedback because you're afraid that
people won't like what you put out there
you can't let that fear run your life or
you'll never accomplish the big things
that you want okay so how do i do it
what are the three steps that i use to
deal with negative feedback that i think
can really benefit you
here we go step number one is always
have empathy if somebody's coming at you
with negativity
with with criticism have empathy
think about if somebody is defaulting in
their life to to negative
their life sucks it's just true like
they are not happy with their life it's
not that they're a negative or nasty
person they just
are not happy with their life right now
if the highlight of their life is coming
to your youtube channel and leaving a
negative post and seeing that you suck
and that's what you're so afraid of this
person's life sucks they hate their life
and i feel bad for them and so when you
when you have empathy when you try to
understand where they're coming from and
recognize that this person is in a
really bad spot in life because humans
are built to serve right
we're built to serve did you get your
copy yet built a serve humans are built
to serve
you are built to serve so why would
somebody leave with negativity they're
they're hurting
they're in pain right now they're in a
worse spot than you are and so
just try to imagine that person hating
their life right now
and it it removes the sting of the words
having empathy removes this it doesn't
hurt you as much
right so like if a baby hits you one's
probably not gonna hurt that much
because it's a baby but two you you you
don't
think that they're maliciously trying to
attack you right it's their baby they
don't know any better this is like treat
those people the same way they don't
know any better they're
they're in a negative cycle loop when
you just happen to got caught up in the
cross hairs
so it removes the sting of the word so
it doesn't hit you as much set number
two is then ask yourself do they have a
point
do they have a point is there anything
to what they're saying that might be
true
most of the time it's probably not to be
honest a lot of times people are leaving
negative comments more just out of their
own frustration than out of any actual
constructive criticism
but a certain percentage of the time it
will be they'll be saying something in a
really nasty negative way
but behind it there's actually something
that you can learn from
and this becomes really important as you
become an entrepreneur and have more
success
is that you need to learn to be able to
take feedback
that's not just sugar-coated if you can
only take feedback when it's nicely gift
wrapped and somebody comes and i love
what you're doing and it's so amazing
and and i've got this one little tiny
idea that maybe it can help you
and but i love you and you're like if
that's the only way that you could take
feedback you're never going to get the
feedback that you need
sometimes the feedback will come from
from somebody who's having a
it's just really nasty or is having a
really bad day right and they'll just
leave a really nasty
comment but when you've removed the
sting from it now you can actually
process it to say
can i learn from this feedback or not
and then set number three is
i always ask myself is my intention good
ask yourself is your intention good if
your intention is good if your intention
is to create something that
serves that helps is trying to have an
impact if that's your intention
it probably is if you're watching this
channel and you're still here if that's
your intention then you have to keep
going
and you're going to make some mistakes
and you're going to let people down and
you will disappoint people and and some
people will be negative and toxic
towards it's going to happen
it will happen but if your intentions
are good
then you have to keep going and so let
that be
the internal compass for you before you
put out your next piece of content
before you design your next t-shirt
before you
make your next product or whatever it is
that you're trying to put out that
you're afraid to put out you want to
create this thing you want to
make this for the world but you're
afraid to put it out ask yourself
is my intention good because people may
not always understand it but as long as
you understand your intention
then it gives at least me the strength
to keep going and keep producing
not everybody likes all my videos but my
intention is always good my intention is
always positive and as i've done more
i've gotten better at making more
and hopefully winning people over but
even when i try something brand new that
doesn't work out
if people flame me my intention was
still good
and so i can live with myself my
intention is not to harm you to screw
you over to make you upset my intention
is to serve
and sometimes i won't be able to do that
well it's okay
keep moving on know that your intention
is good self-love comes from doing
difficult things
self-love self-confidence self-respect
all of it comes from
doing difficult things and praising
yourself for doing them
i think it's one of the most important
things that people don't do enough
but i think in order to actually make
the praise stick
you have to prove to yourself that
you're worthy of it
by doing difficult things you can say
i'm a badass entrepreneur
you can say i'm amazing and i love
myself but why
your brains ain't gonna say well no you
don't
no you don't show me what have you done
you're you're waking up and then the
same thing you did yesterday
at least this is the conversation in my
head so by doing difficult things
by doing the thing even if you don't get
the result
it doesn't matter but the result you're
tying your self-worth your
self-confidence
to the effort to trying the difficult
thing
to taking action on a difficult thing
that you were scared to do if you woke
up every day and did something
that made you scared that was difficult
that made your heart go boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom like that you did
that every day
and then you praised yourself afterwards
for the effort
i promise you're gonna love yourself i
promise you you're going to go off and
do
amazing things you're going to take that
idea that you've got
and go off and actually execute it and
actually implement it
one of the biggest reasons why you're
not is because you don't believe in
yourself
that's why i think lack of belief is the
single biggest problem in the world i'm
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough the woman who solves cancer
is a manager at some restaurant and she
hates her life
because she never believed in herself
enough to actually go down the path that
she should have gone down
because she listened to her parents and
friends and family and society to go do
the same thing
and she's got a safe boring life that
she hates because she doesn't love
herself
and she doesn't believe in herself
enough and so you have to do the things
that make you scared that are difficult
that are difficult
it's not about being fearless it's about
feeling the fear and still going off and
doing it and then saying i'm amazing
because i tried
because if you woke up every day and did
something where you felt amazing that
you tried
you're gonna actually go off and
accomplish amazing things and you're
gonna feel amazing about yourself
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of your biggest fears
you want something more you know you're
capable of something more
you'll come up with a great reason why
you can't do that something more
but really you're just afraid if you
want a breakthrough
if you want that dream life you need to
change the way you think about fear
or it will handicap you for the rest of
your life
so my biggest fear is disappointing
people i'm afraid that whatever i'm
gonna do
i might disappoint somebody and that
keeps me playing small and so whenever i
can recognize it
then i have to go all in and do it just
to show myself because
it allows you to play in a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have
is still there it doesn't go away you're
just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so
what used to count as disappointing
people or my fear of disappointing
people might have been
going to a coffee meeting and helping an
entrepreneur i remember one time
super clearly that i was booking to meet
with an entrepreneur
and i was so worried that i was going to
disappoint her that i was hoping that
she would cancel and the story told
myself was i'm too busy i got all the
stuff to do
you know the realistic reasons
that you can convince yourself right
there weren't stupid reasons they were
realistic but deep down was i'm just
afraid
i'm afraid that she's gonna show up and
i'm not gonna give her value
it's a deep fear and then once i went to
go meet her
it was amazing i remember sitting in my
car and said wow like an hour and a half
ago
i was hoping that she was going to
cancel on me and this is the greatest
thing of all time
right your biggest fears prevent you
from living the life that you want and
so
i'm afraid of disappointing people most
of the time you can't catch it i think
we play small by default i think your
greatest fear
owns you and is giving you tons of
logical reasons why i can't do that
thing
but whenever you catch it whenever you
do watch a couch and say
i think this is just my fear talking
that means it's go
time that means you have to do it just
to teach yourself that you're able to
conquer it and move to a greater level
of success
fear is normal it's part of what makes
you human you would not be human or
you'd have some crazy condition if you
never felt fear
i think the people who say don't be
afraid aren't giving you practical
advice
it's be afraid feel the fear and then
step into it
and do it anyway and the more you get
used to taking on those fearful projects
that you're scared of
the stronger you'll get the more
resistance you'll get the higher
tolerance you'll get
to do bigger better bolder badder things
i think the trick though is spotting the
fear here's what i think happens to most
people
there's some opportunity that comes
along there's some moment that comes
along
whether it's with a client or meeting
somebody or an event
something comes along that you're afraid
of you're afraid of doing it it's going
to stretch you beyond what you've ever
done before
and then what you do is you rationalize
saying no
i don't have the money to go to that
event i'm too busy to go and do that
thing right now
you find the reason why you can't go and
do it you rationalize it
but really deep down the reason is
you're just afraid
and until you spot the fear until you
understand that it's really just the
fear
then you're never gonna solve the
problem so step one
is understanding when there is fear
step two is then stepping into it and
doing it anyway and a lot of this stuff
is just so subconscious
you know we as human beings are kind of
trained to
when we're afraid something's gonna go
wrong and to be
safe and so it's trying to catch that
subconscious action
and proactively change it so as an
example for me when i was starting my
youtube channel
my agent would tell me you have to go
out and do videos in public
i want you to go out on the street i
make a video in public
my natural reaction was
fear but i didn't catch it initially it
was
the gear won't be as good in public you
know i can't control the light settings
i'm going to be bouncing around with the
camera it's not going to be a great
experience
for the people watching why would i do
that i'm rationalizing
a reason why i don't have to do it or
really i'm just afraid
right you could solve all those problems
and he told me
stop being afraid and just go and do it
he cut through it
and let me see my own fear and so i did
it
and when i first went out and filmed in
public i took out it was my phone or my
camera i don't remember
and i'm walking down the street and then
the postman is there
and so as soon as i see the postman i
quiet down
i can put the camera away just walking
normally
and then when the postman leaves i'm
back to filming
and that time i noticed like i'm i'm
doing it because
i'm afraid and i got pissed okay next
time
i gotta speak up next time i gotta do
better
and so i went out and forced myself to
go and do it again
and i was walking past and there were
these construction workers and instantly
again the
the panic sets in like people are
watching these construction workers like
i know they don't really even care
about me and what i'm saying what's
happening on the street
but i forced myself through it it was
awkward it wasn't great i think i had to
redo it
again anyway but i i took the step
i got better at it i recognized the fear
and i jumped into it
and now it's to the point where i'll
make videos walking down the hall and
make videos when i'm at disneyland
disney world you know i'll make videos
in the streets of
anywhere and there's still a moment even
now after how many videos i've done
there's still a moment of
who's watching i think it's natural
normal
it's not as strong as it used to be and
more importantly it doesn't limit me
from doing
the thing that i want to do and so
spotting the fear
and not rationalizing in a way and not
just doing what your subconscious
always does that keeps you down where
you are
is so important being truthful that the
reason why you said no
or you're not taking this opportunity is
just because you're afraid and the
answer
to saying no should never be because i'm
afraid
you want to rejig your system so
whenever that's the answer because i'm
afraid to do it
now you have to do it if you want to
sign up for the entire billionaire
mindset series for free and get the
companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there